A lot of people think China is taking over
the world.
They think that because China has a big economy.
And they're said to be growing still pretty
fast, much faster than the U.S., two or three
times faster.
What's missed there is what's growing even
faster than China's economy is China's debt.
Since 2008, the U.S. has borrowed a lot of
money, but China has borrowed about three
times as much.
We're talking about $20 trillion or so.
The worst performance in world history on
debt.
You go one step down to the industry part,
China does have a very big industrial sector,
probably biggest in the world, bigger than
the United States.
And they're saying it's growing at 6% which
is a pretty fast clip.
But what they don't say is that rail freight,
which is how you'd carry a lot of the industrial
production, is actually shrinking.
They don't say that port freight, which is
another way to carry industrial production,
is growing only about half the speed of industrial
production.
So one possibility is China is building a
lot of stuff.
But it's not going anywhere.
It's just sitting.
It's not being sold which means the companies
that build it aren't making money.
And guess what companies that don't make money
have to do?
They have to borrow.
It gets us back to the debt.
So is the bald guy right?
Let me know in the comments section, and let
us know what other topics you want AEI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds.